a single drop of source magic
[Music]
like flies to honey divinity original
sin to dominated my weekend after its
release as I prepared to leave the
opening area for joy behind me
I made a save and close the game for the
night it was only after I noticed that
my eyes are on fire and the play time
figure popped up on my Steam dashboard
had it dawned on me just how much the
game had grabbed me the sheer density of
adventures and stories along with quirky
side quests bizarre errands and long
conversations with dogs had kept me
firmly locked into the first area the
game for a whole 12 hours so I wrote
that last week and now have 59 hours
played the game so that either means the
game is really good or I have no life or
a combination of both it has been a long
time since an RPG held me in such a
bear-hug of strange tales and quirky
distractions but divinity original sin
too is so dense with alluring stories
and odd encounters but I couldn't stop
myself exploring every inch of that
first area so I want to share with you
some of the reasons why divinity
original sin 2 has grabbed me so hard
and why it might be one of my favorite
RPGs of all time divinity original sin 2
harkens back to the old school RPGs like
Baldur's Gate and Neverwinter Nights but
has also captured the feeling of playing
a true pen-and-paper RPG like Dungeons &
Dragons it's been a while since I've sat
down with a bag of dice and there's
never been a digital experience that has
made me feel those same sensations for
me an RPG is all about options I want to
be spoiled with possibilities to solve
problems with diplomacy or murder my way
out of them if needed and I want to talk
to other players and have them tell me
about solutions I hadn't even thought of
divinity original sin 2 offers all that
and more a small example is when I came
across a group of hostile Sora's hands
now most of the time when you're playing
a game when you find a group of dogs
baring teeth and going for your throat
you'll draw your sword and just feel bad
about it later but in this moment I
wanted to see how creative divinity
original sin 2 allowed me to be first
try the dog charged me and were met with
fireballs and fury loading a save and
returning for a second attempt later I
discovered a thread that led me to
meeting one of the dog's mates on a
beach the worried sand covered pup
expressing concern for his beloved
name-dropping buddy avoided bloodshed
between my party and the pooches
but combat and conversation aren't your
only options
latest stage of my adventure I came
across a red ball that smelled slightly
of dog's breath with this item the
previously bloodthirsty hounds were
distracted by something red and squeaky
and you can progress without murdering
the four canines now that's three
options that I know of just to deal with
the confrontation with some dogs it's a
distraction a sidequest
an optional objective now I'm not even
taking in consideration teleporting
persuading or sneaking past my problems
now take all that possibility and all
those options and put them in a main
quest now I'm especially glad that all
of this is being presented to the player
through actual spoken aloud dialogue yes
even the dogs something that Larian
nearly didn't add to the game but I'm so
glad that they went that extra mile that
was to record over 1 million words of
dialogue to make their world feel more
alive this might seem like a fairly
minor thing for an RPG to have but many
games allow the written word to be
enough but in divinity original sin to
every NPC feels fleshed out living
dynamic they feel unique and engaging
and add a further layer to a world that
I've loved getting lost in the added
benefit of presenting the characters in
the universe in a way that can appeal to
people like me an RPG player who can
find reading reams of text arrghh some 5
hours into a binge session the voice
that you'll be hearing most of all is
that of the narrator the unnamed figure
that tells the tale of your character
directly to the player if you think
about the dialogue systems in games like
Skyrim Mass Effect most of your choices
are written down sentences you assume
your character reads aloud after the
push of a button yet in divinity many of
your options are presented as if you are
telling your dungeon master the
intentions of your next action there's
added a motion body language and
intention written into the conversation
choices she looks up at you with a
mirthless smile but the change in tone
and direction the writing made me feel
like I was more adventurous than player
its injection of personality that allows
you to project your own values of
feelings onto what's being said and done
instead of a static line that you can
just imagine being repeated her pinched
face cracks into a great grin and she
shows the children away from her with a
laugh imagine reading a book but the
story is both about you and your
character all at once as the story
develops so does your character and as a
direct result that changes how your
character is perceived by the world
around you when you first create your
character you'll be given tags matching
your race and gender and are then given
the option to add more to allow you to
mold a background for your adventurer
those actions will give you more tags
tags that suit the style of your
character you're building as your
exploits and renown become more widely
known so to give you an example the
character I'm playing as the moment is a
female lizard so obviously the world
perceives me as a female lizard which
can make for some interesting moments
when you take into account that gender
and race bias exists in the world of
divinity original sin - I've had
characters refused to talk to me because
I was a reptile or other lizards tweet
me with more patience because of my
origin because I took a soldier and
outlawed tags are unique opportunities
to communicate with similar characters
in the world after I earned the hero tag
by being a bit of a goody two-shoes
certain NPCs would treat me as one with
both the positives and negatives that
come with that it reminds me of when
three dog would talk about the exploits
of the vault dweller in Fallout 3 I
would always be so excited to see if the
quest I completed would trigger a little
news reel but in divinity original sin -
it feels like the whole world is doing
that not just the radio presenter the
amount the divinity original sin - seems
to celebrate you as much as your
character as well as giving you a unique
world that you can explore in your own
unique way is a reason why I lost a
whole weekend to it and why it continues
to dominate my free time Larian have
very much built a world for you the
player in the same way that a dungeon
master might build a campaign for their
adventurers you can get as much or as
little out of it as you'd like but it
involves around you it revolves around
you and through the small touches it
feels like it's yours and for a game
that's had such passion surround it and
was born out of a huge success story
from the fan support via Kickstarter I
don't think there's a better way to
please the divinity community it's full
of those wonderful moments that you can
talk about with your friends and it's
been a long time since I felt so
enraptured by an RPG like this but I
would love to know what you think if
you've been playing yourself or just
interest in the game please let me know
what you think in the comments or on
Twitter and I'll try to respond to as
many as I can also I want to hear the
fun names your character has mine is a
female lizard called manda Saleh
I really hope someone out there gets
that
oké if you like the video then please
give that like button we squeeze and if
you want to see more cool stuff like
this then make sure you subscribe we
have a beginner's guide up right now
that you can check out if you're just
getting into this admittedly tricky game
so until next time thank you so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
one